[Music]
in tabloid museum news tabloids by the
American Dream what is the American
dream horses on this other is it the Sal
cocaine perhaps somebody but the recent
movies that I've been watching yourself
I ain't yeah that's some for Tory Ken no
Cuban Colombia Colombian a man the
Colombian drinking I thought the
American Dream was like white picket
fence with that golden retrievers I like
going to retrievers the American dream
is to make money just encapsulates every
dream in one a National Inquirer Museum
has opened in Tennessee oh cool Wow
nobody's gonna go there there's a Museum
of [ __ ] and exaggerated stories yep
sensationalism exhibit so it's a tabloid
Museum exact Christian Bale [ __ ] a
gopher again so it's like he's Christian
Bell wasn't the gear whatever like
Richard Gere David Allen gear Rosie
O'Donnell gives birth to [ __ ] aliens
cut in less like that yeah believe it
sometimes I'm like there must be some
truth in this oh yeah reliable source so
it looks like kismet alien Enquirer live
National Enquirer live is what it's
called Wow because it's cheap real
estate yeah
this would kill in Hollywood though I
know it should be Holly oh yeah just put
that [ __ ] ya know real quick though you
know what's a great idea that I want to
bring that I'd that I went to in New
York to here is something called knit
intended it's called ninja cafe have you
been that [ __ ] no dawg it's the food
maybe how about doing backflips and they
serve you like not that is kinkier than
that oh it's [ __ ] hilarious dude so
like Tim took me here now I took Muriel
there because she came to visit for her
for a birthday [ __ ] so I flew out to New
York so we took her to the ninja cafe
but I didn't tell her what I was about
and so basically they just come on they
scare the [ __ ] out of you I don't
all the time so these come out blood I
like it the most racist way possible
it's always a white mouse no they're
like they're like white Chinese whatever
and it's so [ __ ] funny but Muriel
gets scared about everything so
literally the guy he's not even trying
to scare her he's complicit egos hello
hi so he comes to Greece and she's just
ready for getting scared yeah and then
she was like he greets us and then they
take us to another spot but somehow when
he agreed there so he beats us to it but
once again he wasn't trying to scare her
he just killed her he goes he was let me
show you to your table she goes oh I was
like dude you are hurting this guy's
feelings he hasn't he's like but they'll
literally come up in Agra eating food no
they'll have like a scroll full of the
menu and they'll just come out I'm gonna
do [ __ ] like this oh well here's your
menu no [ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of
you but the funniest [ __ ] was that we
had an Asian waiter and I think he kind
of knew who we were yeah so he was a
little ashamed of himself I was pissed
cuz I come to the restaurant for that
[ __ ] so he would have performed and I'm
talking about this [ __ ] so this is how
sorry he was with his performance he
goes oh here's your menu here's your
menu sir and then this is the most
sorriest thing that he did so cheer she
gets scared easy this what this was is a
ten this is this is your cheer this is a
because I could not a ripoff man I was
so pissed but at the end of it the great
part was our last waiter he was a
magician so he did all this like crazy
magic [ __ ] it was dope I want to take
that concept but bring it here but it's
gonna be crazier after the end of the
meal they [ __ ] step cook with
themselves
people call it samurai didn't know it
comes from yes and mind you the food was
the worst food I've ever eaten in my
life
forgive me Crestor what did you eat they
had sushi but no it was so bad I had to
be something was kill I actually
couldn't eat it but the entertainment
was [ __ ] war that dude like I was so
thoroughly entertained by that one
by the bashful ninja here's your water
sir did he confirm later that he knew
who you were no he just wouldn't make
eye contact about doing these weird like
cycling did it just generally son yeah
he just but everybody else they had like
a white person or a black dude [ __ ]
killed it dude there's one guy he came
up and he just had a sword he went like
that and scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] come on
man just just do it for us but he
wouldn't do it ah but I would take that
concept to bring it here amazing that is
tight the bashful Asian then it's like a
different version of Dick's last resort
yeah where you think cuts you I just
[ __ ] teeth all the time
oh [ __ ] they do that I didn't know that
I think that's a steakhouse they could
your tie off wouldn't it be a dope
concept here if we opened up a ninja
[ __ ] restaurant and all they do is
get scared Kansai is so dope monitoring
part means it
no one's scared cuz they're used to that
[ __ ] especially a minor part yeah
national enquirer live museum so
initially this was reported by a daily
babe beast with this headline
it says National Enquirer live theme
park turns prince of Diana's death into
attraction so then the media went crazy
they're like what the [ __ ] that's
different what are you talking about so
the way that they described it is that
they're they have a ride inside this be
like this sounds like a national inquiry
story though
that's what National Enquirer yeah
they're like the national enquirer yeah
that's great huh okay so they've just
twisted it they skewed the actual truth
and so Daily Beast said that it was a
ride that it takes you through the death
of like Princess Diana limo in the
tunnel yeah in Paris and that it's just
like this crazy spectacle and whatever
the [ __ ] but in reality it's not it's
just this really tiny three foot display
like they're calling it a kiosk where
you walk up and then I'll just show you
a video so it's not even right it's not
a right at all but I wonder away
Princess Diana got assassinated so here
we go
as a museum attraction there are no
rides they prefer just as a theme park
were not a theme park Rick Lanie says he
drove daily beast article but he says
the exhibit in question isn't the flashy
feature from the headlines in the area
of our attraction that they were talking
about is literally a three-foot kiosk we
refer to it as a locator map it's a
three-dimensional map of downtown Paris
it lights up with the path the princess
took and shows the tunnel where she
crashed but it's not a ride and it's
only a small part of the museum that is
literally the only aspect of Diana that
we have in the entire attraction blew it
out of proportion a lot of British
people were like sending very they did
get inquired we accidentally found that
place when we're in putti
we walked by it and we're looking at the
Eiffel Tower because you could see it
from there and then we're like hey what
the hell where are these flowers doing
here and it was like Princess Diana was
one of her sons that pole is bald and
ugly as [ __ ] now I saw I didn't realize
how handsome he was when he was younger
and then recently there's a pic there's
a picture of him but he's like [ __ ]
looks nothing like himself when I was
younger I think it's just a hair because
if you were to get like maybe is that
what it is but he looks really weird
like I say get more like egg shaped
because there's no hair
or even the bottom I think I think
here's a big balancer well yeah so this
is this place oh so they're also asking
you like do you think the Royals kill
Diana do you think she was pregnant with
daddy's baby I think there's definitely
an assassination that went down I think
she got assassinated oh don't you [ __ ] I
don't know why nobody knows why who is
Dodi Fayed E&S today she was like a big
big guy - yeah but yeah so she died in
1997 August 31st and they also show like
the flash that is what blinded the
driver who also died in the crash that
was the driver
Diana and the boyfriend he was a
Egyptian billionaire there we go no the
son of an Egyptian billionaire yeah so
but they also have other other
attractions there where you can see
Michael Jackson that's actually they're
gonna say some fucked-up [ __ ] to him
there's like so it's like there's a lot
of interactive exhibits and so you could
see a lot of their the story like the
headline so here's Michael Jackson when
he had blanket over the balcony and then
statue what is that he was in the hyper
hyperbaric chamber very camber because
they they were able to get a photo of
Michael Jackson in that chamber and then
that was huge news back then what he
legit had a hyperbaric chamber and
they're like Bigfoot they have a Bigfoot
forest that's cool and then what a weird
music it just seems like it's just in
choirs greatest hits yeah pretty much
like that's what sold the most inquiries
like John Lennon when he's dead like wow
this is the last picture oh my god
Whitney Houston I remember Whitney
Houston's photo in her casket I'm like
dad so do you they know what kind of
branding they have themselves but do
they know that we [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] or do they take themselves
seriously
just really loose with our riding but we
really try to give the truth and the lie
I bet you there's like some truth that
they stretch really hard but they do
break some news but it's just all
muddled in the [ __ ] - yeah like on
the slow days for sure they got to make
sure the cool thing is that that's
smarter than to open that because they
have ownership of all of these specific
photos that no one else can use yeah
that's pretty cool like nobody can use
any messages see real estate is cheap
guy maybe that was someone's research
that's where the fans are there's
another location opening in Branson
Missouri in June oh my god Branson
sounds more like it maybe that's where
they sell them yeah yeah they'd like
their target audience cuz every time I
see that at the grocery store I'm like
who's buying this [ __ ]
Darkwing Duck that was born in Branson
oh that's his lying face you national
quiet yourself darkwing duck there are
15 that people can walk through and then
one of them is focused on the road
family called Royals closet and it has
sliding doors and shelves or interactive
walls you can touch and then at the back
of that gallery is the Princess Diana
thing mm-hmm
oh I know what I'm doing if I go to ten
siege engine Forge Tennessee they're
saying that this is a tourist place like
a tourist City where's Motown what like
Motel no no yeah where they have like
the record it Seville USA that like that
originally yeah yeah yeah it's only
Parton I love dolly way I don't know
isn't it tasty also I did in Nashville
Palmer country yeah Nashville Tennessee
that's where it is right so it is Tessie
I thought Motown was Detroit that's why
it does oh maybe I'm putting up because
the cousin Detroit Motor City was like
the mo of like Motown I just know that
boys to Ben song Motown Philly I got the
motor back cities like that around here
with those types of names no we weren't
for out it's so hard like don't do that
don't do that for high school bird for
traffic jam USA that's time they names
rename the city by the characteristics
it has today
cousin [ __ ] Redlands
[Laughter]